ladies and gentlemen please get out your
pencils and play books the program is
about to begin our wheel seated good
morning
oh you guys are the best kindergarten
class ever good morning I am so pleased
to be here I'm so pleased to see so many
bright young shining faces in the room
I'm so glad that c-span is here the last
time I was on c-span the president was
about five feet over there where ken is
right now you asked me to look that's
good yes and I certainly you certainly
hope all of you give us the respectful
silence I received that night I'm
Stephen Colbert if you didn't know that
already please leave the room thank you
very much I'm really a china doll under
the Elvis bluster there are nights I
just rock in bed and whisper to myself
I'm famous and famous I have a book
coming out more a lot more on that later
I hope and people have asked me a lot of
you have asked me this morning what is
the difference between doing late-night
television and doing a book and there is
actually one very interesting difference
in late night television we don't do
anything at 8:00 a.m. on a Saturday are
you crazy my eyeballs are hemorrhaging
but this is book Expo America you got to
come there is no avoiding it you got a
book you people are the pushers of
knowledge it's like junk but I got no
problem with that I'm a free-market
capitalist and for now selling books is
still legal
I certainly hope you were plotting the
possibility of censorship but I did see
one thing out in the lobby you got a lot
of books out there I noticed and one
thing really disturbed me I have no
problem between you know reading between
consenting adults but you people are
selling books to children out there
mm-hmm yeah well come on your product
young that's your that's your game yeah
oh sure sure big tobacco can't give Joe
Camel to an elementary school kid but
give a mouse a cookie no problem
now while those of us who write books
know that we need you for the book
sellers I just think I I speak for all
of us on this panel right now when I say
you are all very good-looking and
intelligent people we all we all would
like to make love with you I put out
it's gonna be very clear about that
if it's gonna help sell books I got I'll
wear something loose to the next one of
these
anyway it is my distinct privilege and
honor to introduce these riders here
today so so distinguished first up is a
friend of my show Ken Burns he's here to
talk about his book the war which is
based on his upcoming PBS series of the
same name that is what we call synergy
in the business by the way I guarantee
people will buy this at the local book
store because otherwise they're gonna
have to drop a hundred and fifty bucks
on a pledge drive
to get it ladies and gentlemen
Ken Burns
good morning I cannot begin to tell you
how wonderful it is despite this early
hour to be introduced by your hero I all
of it though is slightly tempered by the
fact that I live in a little village in
New Hampshire with fewer people that are
in this room and I've had on my
refrigerator there for the last thirty
years old and now faded New Yorker
cartoon that shows two men standing in
hell the flames licking up around them
and one guy says to the other apparently
my over 200 screen credits didn't mean a
damn thing on Sunday September 23rd 2007
at 8 o'clock PBS will begin broadcasting
our 7 part 14 and 1/2 hour series on the
American experience in the Second World
War
entitled simply the war it comes
precisely 17 years to the moment to the
moment from when PBS first broadcast our
series the Civil War in 1990 which is a
bit daunting to think that I have spent
17 years and the only thing I've been
able to do is to remove the words civil
from my work that series began with a
quote from Oliver Wendell Holmes jr. he
said we have shared the in communicable
experience of war we have felt we still
feel the passion of life at its top in
our use our hearts were touched with
fire Holmes was struggling to put into
words what every person who has faced
combat knows in his or her guts that
paradoxically when your life is most
threatened when violent death is
possible at any moment everything
everything is vivified your experience
of life heightened to a state of
awareness not experienced in any other
part of your life we though after we
finished the Civil War series had vowed
not to take on another project about war
we didn't want to seem to be typecast or
exploiting the success of the Civil War
series but we also as emotional
archaeologists did not want to descend
again into that horrific study of loss
and catastrophe and death we took it too
personally in short in that series and
the Magnificent book that Jeffrey C Ward
wrote back then 17 years ago to
accompany it but to statistics invaded
our consciousness that we could not
ignore we learned to our horror that we
are losing in this country 1,000
veterans of the Second World War each
day I am in the memory business memory
is the DNA of history and the notion
that we were losing all of these
recorded memories on the hard drives of
these human beings was a loss to
incalculable to really countenance
second we learned that from statistics
that a huge number of our kids think we
fought with the Germans against the
Russians in the Second World War
graduating high school seniors heading
off in the world to assume the mantle of
leadership so about seven years ago we
decided to let go of the conceit of not
doing it and struggle to produce the
film and the companion book which will
come to you in September we felt that we
could have been excused from doing
anything on the second world war because
in our culture there is everything World
War two around us we are surrounded by
books and television series and
expensive Hollywood movies that
certainly could have given us an excuse
and given us a pass but all of the ones
that were personal lacked the contents
all of the ones that were overarching
lacked the specifics that we so
desperately wanted to communicate we'd
paid lip-service to a bottom up kind of
history that would celebrate what real
so-called ordinary people did in their
lives but actually really hadn't
practiced it and so we decided to
a series and a book that would focus on
real people from four geographically
distributed American towns Waterbury
Connecticut Mobile Alabama Sacramento
California and Luverne Minnesota to get
to know these towns over five or six
years to study the people who would stay
behind and work and worry and grieve to
visit and get to understand the movie
palaces where they would see the
terrifying newsreels of where their sons
were and most of all follow those sons
into hell not the good war of our public
relations and subsequent bloodless
gallant myth but of course ladies and
gentlemen the worst war ever
we felt that too many of the war works
good as well as bad placed something
between us and our experience of that
extraordinary Cataclysm the greatest
Cataclysm in human history we describe
it too often we are distracted by an
unnecessary interest in celebrity
generals and politicians too often we
are distracted by an obsessive interest
in armaments and weaponry too often we
focus only on strategy and tactics too
often we demonize our enemies and become
obsessed with swastikas and all things
Nazi and all things 8 if Hitler Adolf
Hitler and we forget to our peril that
nearly 60 million human beings died in
this Cataclysm 60 million human beings
that young men from our country left
small towns and went and became
professional killers for a few years saw
and did unspeakable things came home and
helped to create the world that provides
us the kind of luxury that permits us to
have a wonderful breakfast such as this
and we attempted to try to honor that it
is the film we could not have made 10
years ago these men were not speaking
about their experiences and it is of
course a film that in five years we
could not make it is these people will
have passed from the scene and so it was
incumbent upon us to try to
tell the story of these so-called
ordinary people as the teaser shows you
begin to understand that there are no
ordinary lives we have with each of our
major films attempted to produce the
book that is not a companion book but a
standalone volume that could even
without the series do justice to the
complexity of the subjects that we found
17 years ago when the Civil War series
came out it was accompanied by the book
that Alfred a Knopf produced on the
Civil War and became a bestseller
because though it was attached to the
project it stood alone and today is used
in classrooms Geoffrey Ward who could
not be here with me today the principal
author of the text of the book his
father is not well he is of that
generation and I have worked for years
and years and years to ensure that this
book will stand alone you know one of
the great lessons of the Second World
War it seems to me is that we in shared
sacrifice made ourselves richer we live
in a media culture that it is so
dialectically preoccupied this day
everything is good or bad
young or old black or white north or
south east or west red state or blue
state and we forget to select for those
aspects of our national character that
remind us why we agreed to cohere we are
so impoverished now despite the great
riches that we have because we lack the
ability to connect as we did back then
when in shared sacrifice paradoxically
we made ourselves richer so in a way you
know Arthur Schlessinger the great
historian who died a few weeks ago said
that there's too much poor of us and not
enough Unum he was right all of the work
that we've tried to do is to celebrate
that Unum and I can't begin to tell you
in any film or book that we have
approached anything that has come closer
to touching that central thing about why
we Americans unlike any other people on
earth agree to cohere why we are still
stitched together by were
it's the currency of why we are here in
this building and most important they're
dangerous progeny ideas I look so
forward to sharing with you this book in
this film in September we're very happy
to report that those supporting the film
have committed more than 10 million
dollars to advertising the existence of
the public television broadcast 10
million dollars of advertising to let
people know not only about the series
but about this magnificent book about a
companion soundtrack from Sony that has
an amazing tune my Norah Jones on it the
Civil War series 17 years ago was the
highest-rated still remains the
highest-rated series in the history of
Public Television and part of our
anxiety about this free agency that we
all find ourselves in today we all drive
in our cars alone we all look at the
internet alone we're all watching
television alone there is a kind of
singularity to our pursuits the great
anxiety is that we won't be able except
in moments of great national tragedy to
come together where you could have a
common and shared experience we are
trying awfully hard at public television
and at alfred knopf
and it's soni to bring a kind of shared
experience to all of you this fall and i
look forward to working with all of you
to helping to make this the success that
i think it will be in the course of our
studies we got to know the reporting's
of Eric severide he had parachuted into
the Burmese jungle during the Second
World War
reporting for CBS reports he had marched
across France he had been almost
everywhere but at the end of the war he
had confessed to his readers that
everything he had sent back had been a
failure that he hadn't been able to get
to the essence of war that in fact the
journalist the observer who covered it
didn't have any chance to really report
because he was there by choice as
opposed to the soldier and the
incredible internal life that they lived
who
they're not by choice and then he said
this remarkable thing he said war
happens inside a man and that is why in
a certain sense you and your sons from
that war will be forever strangers if
the miracle of art and genius in later
years two or three among them can open
their hearts and the right words come
out then perhaps we shall know a little
of what it was like and we shall know
then that all the present speakers and
writers hardly touched the story we'd
heard the echo in the Civil War when
Walt Whitman said future years will
never know the seething hell the black
infernal background the countless minor
interiors of the secession war and it is
best they should not the real war
Whitman warned will never get in the
books I don't know how close we've come
to getting in the book or by what art or
genius might have been present but for
us as filmmakers and writers being
privileged to bear witness to the
testimony of the 40 odd people you will
meet in this film people we hope that
you will get to know like family members
people you could have had Thanksgiving
with that they will remove the mantle of
strangeness from this horrible thing
that human beings do this great lie of
civilization war and that we can come to
terms with this greatest Cataclysm it is
of course the intersection of the very
worst of us we're so much brutality so
much suffering so much killing so much
loss takes place but it is also
paradoxically were the best of us also
emerges and that was also what we sought
to seek and bring back from our
investigations and I'm so excited to be
able to share the series and the book
with you this fall and so grateful for
your attention this morning thank you so
much
thank you Ken
thank you ken I just want to say for the
record that I I knew we fought against
the Germans and if it weren't for our
allies the Japanese we could never have
won harrowing harrowing time for our
country by the way I also want to thank
Ken for inspiring me to grow this beard
today I was not to be out distinct can
we have a beard off for a second please
I was not to be out distinguished by you
all right will yours have frames who's
more distinguished okay
who's more distinguished right let's
vote let's vote let's vote right
I'll do something serious someday and
everyone will laugh next up is the
author of Snow Flower and the Secret Fan
which I believe was the novelization of
a kung fu movie her new book is peony in
love which follows three women in 17th
century China who become obsessed with a
famous opera which is thought to have
thought to cause love sickness even
death and I am glad somebody out there
as finally have had the courage to write
about the life-threatening dangers of
opera does get talked about enough in
our culture please welcome Lisa C
before I talk about how I came to write
peony in love I just want to say thank
you when I started writing snow flower
in the Secret Fan I thought no one is
going to read this book and people would
say to me you know no one is going to
read this book it's about China it's in
the nineteenth century it has women
living in seclusion with bound feet oh I
like this one too people are gonna think
you're a lesbian all of these things and
I thought well okay so no one's gonna
read this book and I even had a number
in my mind I thought well if I'm really
lucky about five thousand people will
read this book but they'll be the right
five thousand and in a way this was very
freeing for me because it allowed me to
really go deeper into myself to really
cut to the bone to go to those places
that are really dark and sad and
actually very scary when you're writing
and because of that or along the way
somehow you embrace this story of lily
and Snow Flower and in in the way that
you did that you have so encouraged me
to have the courage to go to those dark
places to go to those scary places to go
to those places where it's just like oh
god anyway so thank you really okay
thank you for putting me through torture
every day so onto peony in love I have
always been interested in stories that
have been lost forgotten or deliberately
covered up and this really begins with
my own family
my great-great-grandfather came to this
country to work on the building of the
Transcontinental Railroad and I like to
think of this man is one of the original
deadbeat dads you were supposed to come
here work hard save up your money and
send it back home to your family in
China not my great great grandfather he
had a fondness for women and gambling
something that continues in our family
even today
and as a result his wife and family back
in China they were so poor that my
great-great grandmother used to carry
people on her back from village to
village to support her children finally
some people took pity on her and lent my
great-grandfather who was 14 years old
the money to come to the gold mountain
in the United States by that time the
railroad was completed and he found his
father working in Sacramento he said you
know dad you're a bum
go home and he did and my
great-grandfather stayed and he did a
lot of the jobs that immigrants do even
today he worked in the field few wash
dishes and restaurants he swept up in
factories but by the time he was 30 in
the 1880s in Sacramento he had his first
business it was a factory that
manufactured crotchless underwear for
brothels
everyone has to have their beginning in
America that's ours you know this man
turned out to be pretty interesting as I
started looking into his life he used to
sell tickets to see his stuffed mermaid
he was the first Chinese in America to
own an automobile he lived to be a
hundred years old he had four wives many
of them simultaneously of course that is
illegal in this country but you know no
matter 12 children the last born when he
was in his 90s this is long before the
age of I address so a real
accomplishment anyway in the process of
looking at my own family I could see
first of all that what you could look
for and what you could find and the
things that people tell you are not
always really the truth that there were
these stories out there that we're
fascinating but also that you could look
at history and see how it affected
individual people and I think that
that's something that all of us on this
panel have today especially when you
hear from Kyle that as well
so later when I came across this secret
writing that was used by women in one
very remote county in China the only
writing system to have been found
anywhere in the world to have been used
exclusively by women I thought how could
this exist and I didn't know and then I
thought well how could this exist and we
all didn't know because so often you
hear about women in the past that there
were no women writers there were no
women artists there were no women
historians there were no women chefs I
could go on and on but of course there
were women who were doing these things
it's just so often what they did was
either lost forgotten or deliberately
covered up so in the process of writing
about Snow Flower and lily for Snow
Flower in the Secret Fan and writing
about this secret language
I kept coming
cross this other group of women who had
lived in the 17th century in Hangzhou
and I like to think of these women is
kind of a reverse mirror image of the
women in Snow Flower in the Secret Fan
in Snow Flower these women were poor
uneducated living in isolation with tiny
tiny bound feet these women in Hangzhou
were from very wealthy families highly
highly highly educated they also had
bound feet meaning that when they were 5
years old their feet their toes their
bones and their feet had been broken
molded reshaped until they had feet the
size of your thumbs about one inch wide
and three inches long and yet in this
area in the 17th century there were more
women writers who were being published
than all together in the rest of the
world at that time
now of course there weren't very many
women being published in the rest of the
world at that time and I'm sure if we
all put our heads together we might come
up with about five if we were lucky but
in the Yangtze Delta in the 17th century
there were over a thousand women who
were being published who were widely
read who traveled around China in the
17th century equivalent of book tours
and I thought well how could those women
have existed and I didn't know and why
didn't we all know about them and also
how could this be how could these women
have done that
well the thousand years ago the poet
hunuen wrote all things not at peace
will cry out and that's what how it was
for these women the mid 17th century in
China saw the man shoes in a China the
Ming Dynasty fell the Ching dynasty was
formed and for about thirty years there
was this tremendous social upheaval
millions of people died millions of
people were forced out of their homes it
was particularly hard for women they
were sold on strings by their around
their necks
strings of fish they actually had less
value per pound than salt but there were
other women who were still kind of
isolated and inside anyway thirty years
of social disorder with the result that
the men weren't really paying attention
to the women and they left the gate open
and these women's snuck out and they
became professional writers professional
artists professional historians
professional adventurers professional
archers archers and they traveled all
over the country and they did these
amazing things and after about 30 years
society calm down the men kind of woke
up they said get back inside and those
women did go back inside the gate was
shut and there they remained for 300
years
Panty and love is based on the true
story of three lovesick maidens these
lovesick maidens were kind of a
subcategory of these women writers in
the 17th century these were these young
girls ages 13 to 16 who loved an opera
called the peony pavilion they were
never allowed to see it they could only
read it so it's not really opera it's
reading that they that kill them
and as they read this opera which was
about a young girl who was so moist 'red
and so kept in her house that she didn't
even know her family owned a garden that
when she went outside she caught a case
of lovesickness wasted away and died and
came back to LA came back to earth as a
ghost and in the process found the love
of her life who then brought her back to
life through true love she was the first
heroine in all of Chinese literature to
actually choose her own destiny so these
young girls in real life who had no
choice in their futures who were already
betrothed to be married who knew exactly
what was going to happen from the time
they were five until they died they
would read this opera and they would
think if I died too maybe I could have a
choice in my own future and so they
would catch cases of love sickness and
waste away and die and as they were
dying many of them wrote stories and
poems which were then published after
their deaths so if you go back to your
bookstores today or next week and look
in collections of Chinese poetry you'll
see that some of them are still in print
today anyway Fenian love is based on the
true story of three of these lovesick
maidens who are all married to the same
man one right after the other the first
one was a 16 year old girl from a very
wealthy family who loved the peony
pavilion but she caught a case of love
sickness and she would in stay in bed
and write her thoughts about love in the
margins and about all of these things
that she desired in life but thought she
would never have but of course she
wasted away and died many years later
the man she was supposed to marry he
married again to another
sixteen-year-old girl and he gave her
this copy of the peony pavilion with all
of her thoughts with all of the first
wife's thoughts written in it and now
the second wife started adding her
thoughts about love about destiny in the
margins of this opera
she lent this copy to some friends who
took it around Hangzhou and pretty soon
people in Hangzhou were saying who could
have had such amazing insights about
love and she said because she was a very
good Chinese wife oh my husband and he
became very famous for this and he was
the one who traveled all around the
country
with these all of these great thoughts
that had actually been written by these
two women well of course this second
wife got a case of love sickness and
wasted away and died he married again
about ten years later by this time he
was in his 40s this time to a 13 year
old girl and while she was educated she
wasn't perfectly educated so he used to
have her sit on his lap while he taught
her to read the classics to really
understand poetry I'm sure other things
were going on as well as she sat on his
lap but we won't go there and after
three years he finally felt that she was
ready and he gave her that same copy of
the peony pavilion she was a bit of an
idiot and she now started adding her
thoughts into the margins but she also
did something else she had kind of
entered into this dialogue with these
other women and they seemed to be
calling to her and she seemed to be
answering and she wasn't like those
first two women she didn't catch a case
of lovesickness instead she took all of
her wedding jewelry and pawned it so
that this project could be published and
it was the fifth published as the three
wives commentary and it was the first
book of its kind to have been written
and published by women anywhere in the
world and in China it remained in print
for 300 years
so peony and love to me is about those
emotions that are so strong love hate
envy desire regret these emotions that
are so strong that they transcend
borders they transcend time and perhaps
they
transcend the veil of death it's about
the bonds of female friendship
it's about those ties that bind us from
grandmother to mother to daughter and
how that string can sometimes get
tangled and sometimes get frayed but no
matter what we are linked from mother to
daughter down through the generations
it's about the power of words and
literature and ultimately it's about the
desire that women have and men too to be
heard but especially women for whom it's
so hard so I'd like to just end with
this quote from the third wife on my
little yellow post-it why is it that in
the past women's thoughts have been like
flowers in the wind drifting off with
the breeze and vanishing without a trace
with my work I'm hoping to find those
lost women's voices their creations
their thoughts so that we can learn from
them we can experience what they did and
finally perhaps hear them for who they
were and along the way what I hope is
that we all can find our own voices and
be heard for who we are as well thank
you so much
thank you Lisa your knowledge of 17th
century China approaches even my own I
do I do have one announcement if you
contract a fatal case of lovesickness
the Centers for Disease Control's ask
that you not get on a transatlantic
flight to Greece very irresponsible next
he is the author of The Kite Runner a
book I have not read but I assume it is
the uplifting story of a boy who loves
kites and running I'm free-balling that
one
I love yo-yo so I can relate his latest
book is called a thousand suns great
another book about global warming
please welcome Khaled Hosseini
thank you very much thank you
it's a thrill being here this is my
first be ei I never been to this
organized chaos that is a be ei and I
want to address you booksellers who in
many ways are responsible for the
success of my book because you loved it
from the beginning and you shoved it in
the hands of readers and urge them to
read it so I thank you for that all your
great debt but before I address you
I want to address our MC who I am a huge
fan of and I got to meet him backstage
don't clap yet'
but I have been dying for this chance
mr. Colbert to unleash the ire of the
people upon you and to disclose these
fine folks and indeed to America at
large that you trash the Kite Runner
that's right mr. Ducey fan 55 you can't
hide from us you were on Amazon and give
the Kite Runner and F - let me explain
something to you mr. Colbert it is
unamerican to diss the kite runner
you have no idea what you're messing
with hell hath no fury like the wrath of
a scorned type on a fan now you know how
the president felt
in all seriousness when I am on the road
and I've been on the road for a few days
I often get asked if I always wanted to
be a writer that I know wanted to be a
writer when I was growing up when I was
growing up I wanted to be Clint Eastwood
I still do I also wanted to be a
diplomat like my dad and I won't be a
teacher like my mother for a while I
want to be a pilot then I wanted to be a
karate expert guy and then I wanted to
be this detective like Mike Hammer and
have a gun that I would call Betsy and
have this hot sultry gun-toting
secretary named Belle de curiously
enough I never told my parents that want
to be a doctor or a writer my eventual
professions probably saw us to not raise
false hopes and the former or cause
undue anxiety in the latter but
officially I became a doctor first
though I think that I was a writer long
before I shipped off that first medical
school application I began writing like
the boy and the Kite Runner
Ahmir when I was a kid growing up in
Kabul in the 1970s and I wrote poems and
I wrote little plays that would coax my
siblings and my cousins into staging for
our parents at at parties and I wrote
little short stories and my recollection
of those early stories is that they were
dark intense that they were unabashedly
even proudly melodramatic and that their
own albeit very primitive and childish
way dealt with issues of loyalty and
friendship and even class struggle and
that they made up with a big winning
expansive heart or what they lacked in
subtlety and style words
some people have used maybe with some
justification to describe the Kite
Runner and though the language in which
I've written has changed I you know
began writing in Farsi and then I wrote
in French and now I mostly write in
English one thing has remained constant
is that I've always written for an
audience of one
for me writing has always been a selfish
self-serving act of telling myself a
story you know something grabs my
interest and compels me I have to sit
down and see through this is how the
Kite Runner was written I had in mind
these two boys one who was conflicted
and on very unsure moral ground the
other pure and loyal and rooted in
integrity and I knew that their
friendship was doomed and that they
would be falling out and that their
falling out would impact the lives of
those around them in a profound way and
how and the why of that will happen was
the compulsion the compulsion that led
me to sit down and begin writing that
novel back in in March of 2001 I never
intended to get that novel published
even when I was as far as two-thirds of
the way through the writing of it and
like Lisa
I ain't never crossed my mind that
anybody would actually read that novel
although I thought my wife probably
would because she loves me so you can
imagine my astonishment at the reception
that that novel has received worldwide
since its publications you know I cannot
tell you how surreal it was to learn
that it's fans included Howard Stern and
first lady Laura Bush if not sadly
Stephen Colbert
I got letters from India from London
from Sydney from Paris from Arkansas
from all over the world from readers who
expressed a passion to me many of them
wanted to know how to send money to
Afghanistan some told me they wanted to
adopt an Afghan orphan and in those
letters you know I saw the unique
ability that fiction has to connect
people who dress differently speak
differently practice different religions
and I saw how Universal some human
experiences are friendship
yields forgiveness loss and atonement
and in those letters I also saw how
unwittingly
I had placed myself in a daunting
position that of following up the Kite
Runner and of writing the book that
through no fault of its own would bear
the burden of comparison to the Kite
Runner while the ink was still wet on
his pages the reading of every fan
letter I received was punctuated by a
loud and anxious gulp and I felt pity
for this as yet unwritten novel and I
feared for the sanity of my family who
would have to bear with me as I said
about writing this book and I had
further complicated matters by deciding
on a narrative that demanded not one but
two central characters both of them
women and this was a decision that I'd
made back when I was putting the final
edits on the Kite Runner which was a
father-son story said exclusively in the
world of men I had decided at that time
for better or for worse that I would
write another love story set in
Afghanistan there would be a mother
mother-daughter tale and that it would
be about the inner lives of these two
struggling Afghan women and I suppose
there were some easier roads I could
have gone down but I chose this one
because both as a writer as
Afghan I couldn't think of a more
riveting or more important more
compelling story than the struggle of
women in my country dramatically
speaking every other topic paled in
comparison
unfortunately the image of the burqa
wearing woman walking past the stern
glaring look of a Taliban official has
become familiar around the world perhaps
even iconic I was in Kabul in 2003 and I
remember I met this guy who worked as a
bodyguard for a government official and
he told me kind of casually their story
about a woman he'd seen beaten by a
Taliban official on the street and in
telling that story he used a rather
grisly if colorful expression
he said he beat her until her mother's
milk licked out of her bones and
listening to that story it was it seemed
unreal to me that he was talking about
this happening in Kabul that not long
ago women in Afghanistan were professors
at universities there were doctors and
there were lawyers they worked in
hospitals they taught at schools and
they played an important role in society
women like my mother who was a teacher
at Farsi in history the University
educated eventually became the
vice-principal of a very large high
school for girls but that was Kabul and
Afghanistan is not a nation of urbanized
middle-class people there's always been
an ideological gap between liberal
reformist Kabul and rural Afghanistan
and the sad truth is that Taliban style
oppression of women in certain regions
of Afghanistan existed long before the
Taliban or even a twinkle in the loving
eye of the Pakistani secret intelligence
whereas Kabul has been
speaking a hub for female autonomy rural
Afghanistan especially south and east
along the border with Pakistan has been
traditionally a patriarchal
male-dominated tribal region where men
have decided the face of women in those
regions women have always lived in
confinement they have always worn the
burqa on the street in those regions
women have rarely gone to school beyond
the age of 12 and so there's always been
rampant illiteracy in those areas for
centuries women there have been told
when they will marry who they will marry
and incidentally for how much and for
the most part rule Afghan women have led
quiet subterranean lives of obedience
and service now this may surprise you
but throughout the last century there
were multiple attempts to liberate as it
were the women of Afghanistan
originating in Kabul we had a king named
Amano Lujan back in the in the 1920s who
actually banned banned the wearing of
the burqa in public he built the first
hospital for women the first school for
girls
he brought teachers from Europe to teach
girls
he sends women abroad to Europe to get
an education he tried to ban forced
marriage to raise the minimum marrying
age for girls to 16 and to ban the
practice of bride-price
unfortunately largely as a result of
these attempts he was run out of town
and there was a rebellion he ended up
living an old dying an old man in exile
there were other attempts in the 50s and
the 60s some of which had fruition in
1964 Afghan women gained the right to
vote and there were other attempts again
in the late 1970s but cobbles reforms
have always been met by the patriarchy
all tribal leaders with
akari contempt or in some case mutiny as
in the case of poor king Amano lejana so
as you can see life has always been a
struggle for some women in Afghanistan
well before the Taliban but it became
all but unbearable with the outbreak of
factional war anarchy and extremism in
some ways that's when disaster really
struck women suffered not only through
the bombings and the indiscriminate and
unforgiveable shelling of civilian areas
like everyone else not only they were
beaten and tortured and humiliated and
imprisoned not only they had their
fundamental human rights violated over
and over again but in large numbers they
also suffered from gender-based abused
they were abducted and sold as slaves
abroad they were forced into marriage to
militia commanders they were forced into
prostitution and they were raped a crime
particularly heinous and unforgivable
that was used to intimidate families who
were opposed or one faction or another
today in post Taliban post 9/11
Afghanistan there is talk again of
liberating women as there should be the
gender apartheid that has been forced on
Afghan women has been one of the great
unresolved in justices of modern world
and in addition Afghanistan needs its
women the whole project of rebuilding
Afghanistan is doomed if the fundamental
human rights of its women are not
respected and if its women are not
allowed to participate the following is
a quote by Queen Soraya wife of King
Amanullah Hahn who said do not think
however that our nation needs only men
to serve it
women should also take their part as
women it in the early years of Islam the
valuable services rendered by women are
recounted throughout history and from
their examples we learned that we must
all contribute toward the development of
our nation the Queen said those words
back in 1926 and it seems to me that her
words are as relevant today 80 years
later perhaps even more so and the world
back then and I'll close by saying that
I went back to Kabul in 2003 I met
people from all walks of life and I
remember standing at street corners and
seeing these women fully covered walking
on the street trailed by four or five
six seven children and I remember
thinking who is that person inside you
know what are what has she seen what has
she endured what makes her happy what
gives her sorrow what are her hopes
you know her longings her
disappointments my new novel of Thousand
Splendid Suns is in some ways my attempt
at imagining some answers to those
questions it's my attempt to explore the
inner lives of these two fictional women
and to look for their very ordinary
humanity beneath their veils a Thousand
Splendid Suns is very very dear to me it
has been for me a labor of love and I
hope that it doesn't sound too
pretentious if I say that I think of it
as my modest tribute to the great
courage and endurance and resilience of
Afghanistan I hope that that novel will
move you on that I will engage you that
I will transport you and that it will
leave you with some sense of sense of
compassion and empathy for Afghan women
whose suffering has been matched by very
few groups
in the recent world history I thank my
my friends on the panel I thank all of
you for listening to me and for your
support and encouragement of my writing
thank you very much
thank you fella and I'd like to
apologize or having trashed your book on
Amazon I was mad at you at the time I
don't I don't remember why but if you've
seen my show you know it doesn't matter
why it's just that I get mad is the key
and I know the danger of attacking the
Kite Runner shortly after that my my
front yard was filled with women's book
clubs wielding torches in one hand and
cheap white wine in the other Friday
night around seven o'clock so I
apologize thank you very much
our final author could not be with us
this morning he said and I want to get
this right to hell without I'm going to
sleep I'm I'm sorry he couldn't be here
he's a man I respect more than anyone
I've ever known
and I have met Deepak Chopra please
welcome via satellite esteemed mr.
Stephen Colbert I'm sorry I couldn't be
with you there today but I am here in my
underground studio bunker putting the
finishing touches on my book I am
America and so can you a book so good it
is destined to win the Stephen T Colbert
award for the literary excellence eat it
the road futuristic novel right where
are the robots and the large-breasted
aliens and the large breasted alien
robots sorry it's a downer - spoiler
alert - bad Cormac I could have helped
you push some paper I'm sure you all
know if you read the New York Times and
something tells me this crowd does if
you've got a serious book to peddle you
gots to be on my show then an author
gets what statisticians call The Colbert
bump for the first time this morning I'm
gonna bump myself I am America and so
can you is a handy reasonably priced
home
details everything that's wrong with
America from illegal immigrants
overrunning our borders to old people
sponging off Social Security to baby
carrots trying to make me gay so small
so tender now I've got something of a
confession to make here up till now I've
never been a fan of books they've always
seemed like they were written by someone
other than me but for some reason this
book really speaks to me
plus there's pictures again the road you
really drop the ball so I wrote this
book for the heroes and who are the
heroes the people who buy my book at
full price 25% off is for cowards
this book brings the truth it brings it
hot and it brings it hard and it brings
it all night long and yes that is a
sexual metaphor reading my book will be
like your first time frightening while
it happens but once it's over you want
to brag to everyone you know I don't a
pony punches I go after some sacred cows
like higher education we all know that a
little knowledge is a dangerous thing
but does it not automatically follow
them that a lot of knowledge must be an
extremely dangerous thing I say college
is good for only one reason it is one of
the best places to join secret societies
and become one of the future masters of
the universe did you know that 40 of our
43 presidents were members of secret
societies did you also know that I just
made that statistic up my whole book is
loaded with useful information like that
you see folks I hold my truths to be
self-evident that's why I don't do
research but there's also some fun in
the book for kids that's why I'm
laughing after every chapter be it sex
and dating or the Hollywood agenda
there's what I call a fun zone like this
brain teaser from the media chapter a
limo driver has been dispatched to bring
proper Carlson James Carville and a
Boston cream pie from MSNBC headquarters
in New Jersey to a big-time press event
in Manhattan but due to cutbacks at
MSNBC the limo can only carry one thing
at a time
the limo driver can't leave Carlson
alone with Carville because Carville is
insane and will attack and destroy
Carlson and of course one can't leave a
Boston cream pie alone with Tucker
Carlson
how will the pundits and the desert get
across the Hudson River to the event
think you know the answer
buy the book and find out I am America
and so can you
you'll love it so much you want to buy
to one to read while you're at home and
one to read while you're driving well if
you'll excuse me I've got to go back to
putting a polish on this thing bye wow
that was good
now I'd like to open the floor to any
questions I'll I'll prime the pump can i
buy your book in bulk yes I believe we
have some microphones out in the
audience does anyone have any questions
for me my life is an open book and I'm
not afraid of you yes I see a hand right
over there yes hi what's your name hi
Caroline what's your question my
question is which of these books here
was was your favorite and that's a dress
- uh I I like all of their books very
much because um because I'm a nice
person my character likes my book more
well thanks for those questions another
question yes Oh Amy Sandberg I have a
question for mr. burns
would you tell ok you can have a
question for him but I get to answer it
go ahead let's hit it
are you can you send up a flare oh yeah
yes stand up please would you tell the
audience about the veterans history
project my kids are involved in that and
I think everybody would love to hear
about it I know it's an extension of
your of your documentary but also and
you can address this mr. Colbert as well
what is what do you think is necessary
for children of this generation going
through school to have the sense of
patriotism and sacrifice that the
veterans of World War two seem to have
having interviewed several of them my
kids seem to feel a disconnect with that
idealism and sacrifice and patriotism
the UNAM that you were talking about
what what could bring that about for I
think the quickest way would be World
War 3
but ken do you have another idea and
mine's most practical and the quickest
go ahead I think this is the essence we
live in not only a media culture but a
consumer culture where our kids are
taught that if they just know the names
of high brands of blue jeans or handbags
if they can just purchase things
everything will be all right but of
course it won't be all right some the
inevitable vicissitudes that visit all
of us will inevitably
intrude in into even the most carefully
planned existence and so for me
among the many number of things that we
can share in common I find a shared past
is important these kids you may not know
whether we've bought with or against the
Germans all have DV cameras they can go
to Grandpa and Grandma to uncle Charlie
to the guy down the street and start
asking questions we knew when we began
our series that this would be a kind of
poem and not a textbook that this would
be anecdotal like the poet William Blake
we thought you could find the universe
in a grain of sand that in the stories
in our book it was possible to touch on
universal human themes and so we reached
out and encouraged public television
which had in a rather haphazard fashion
after our Civil War baseball and jazz
series encouraged the local stations
local affiliates to produce local
stories related to the Civil War
baseball in jazz now nearly every one of
the 354 affiliate stations are doing
essentially a version of our film going
out in their local community finding
veterans talking to them trying to
understand the warp and Wolf wealth of
that community back then when in that
paradoxical idea that shared sacrifice
where we gave things up we actually made
ourselves Richard not just in spirit but
in pocketbook and now as we refuse to
give up anything I think we were told at
this last and 9/11 that the only thing
we needed to do was to go shopping and
yet we feel an incredible poverty
of spirit we've also expanded this
further and we've entered into a
partnership with the Library of
Congress's veterans oral history project
and we are encouraging people around the
country to take those DV cameras and to
go and record their grandparents or
their parents and who are now just now
as we discovered in our film and in our
book just now beginning to be willing to
tell their stories the intimations of
their own mortality have brought them to
this moment of understanding that their
memory is their greatest asset and most
important our greatest inheritance and
if you can go to the website of the
Library of Congress or of the PBS site
and download some very simple
instructions from us on how to light and
shoot these things some sample questions
a registration form you can keep this of
course for your own family and for the
incredible glue that I think that that
represents in this emotional archeology
we're all trying to attempt to keep us
together but if you make a copy and
share it with a grateful Republic and
send it to the Library of Congress we
will begin to exponentially collect the
the recollections of this unusually
reticent generation and have with us
forever at least some where a corrective
a correlative to all of this kind of
mindless in the present consumerism that
keeps us from understanding the ways in
which we have so much in common and the
ways in which this mindless consumer
society divides us apart and insists us
on being independent free agents and
that will be to our apparel if we
continue that task and I think strangely
enough paradox they enough in order to
know where you are in order to know
where you're going you have to know a
little bit of
where you've been and I think these
magnificent people now at the end of
their lives finally in some cases
beginning to speak for the first time
about events almost too horrible to
remember can be in a way our salvation
for the record excellent
for the record Ken's answer will be
transcribed and available as his next
book yes some glasses
Oh mr. Colbert it's it's it's just an
honor to have you here and be able to
talk to you that's a great opening go
ahead yes I wanted to say that I
videotaped your Korean rap music video
that was and I watch it on a regular
basis but this isn't what I wanted to
ask you um you speak Korean
dim sum no I do it I don't that isn't
even Korean
um here's my question I have two
questions one is the publishing industry
is in a great state of change as I
understand I don't do a lot of research
like you do but I've heard that the
self-publishing independent small
presses are really making a way into the
industry and the big houses are getting
a run for their money and my question is
how would a girl like me who just put
out a book called imagining Einstein
essays on m-theory World Peace in the
science of compassion which just won an
indie press award how would someone like
me go on I came from Tommy Nelson school
shameless self-promotion so I'm sorry my
question is how would someone like me
get on your show and secondly were you
really serious about that making love
part because the whole table over here
is just right I don't think I don't
think you need to be on my show you were
just on c-span too
and that's got a much broader reach then
late night comedy does and you know
we'll see how my sales go before we
figure out whether I'm gonna give it up
how many of you ever had sex to sell
books any of you come on we know you're
not a lesbian
you already told us yes sherry I have to
say what I think you said to Ken Burns
on your show couldn't a worn a tie well
I walked I on the tape I can't actually
make a Windsor knot this early yeah you
can do it it better clip on but is it
real okay because you're on public
television then we know that yes and you
have a follow-up question I was actually
interested
I love the wide range of guests you have
on your show and do them good and the
way that you have authors who are
talking about science or religion in
particular which I think are some of
your or your characters interests um
that we don't see very much of on TV and
just that in general your show has
opened up this cultural space for
authors to talk and be heard so I wanted
to congratulate you for that again an
excellent question
this one yes go ahead coming I wanted to
know more about how you choose who's
gonna be on the show and I don't know if
this is classified information no no
it's an easy question but like do you
tell your Booker who you wanna have does
she tell you what the first thing I do
when I get I get a list every so often
to people who are gonna be on the show
and I look at the list as my character
and I think do I have my shows not about
thinking my shows about feeling you know
and it's it's I believe that the brain
is a secondary organ and and so I try to
cut off my brain when I look at
listen I think would my character feel
any way about this person and you know
Ken was easy because he was an icon of
Public Television which I believe isn't
like you know the Politburo you know
service that's what PBS stands for and
and so I have an if I have an immediate
emotional reaction to the person as a
character or something iconic or
representing an industry or an idea like
evolution or Elaine Pagels coming on
talking about the Gospel of Judas that
is that immediately my character has a
visceral reaction to that so I know I
can generate something and then
sometimes I'm just interested in the
person well the most challenging thing
about my show is that I'm really
interested in religion I'm really
interested in science and you know as
somebody was raised by you know a mother
who was a mystical Catholic and a father
was an immunologist those things you
know mixing me in in an interesting way
I think it's a nice combination it did
not make you immune to mysticism
unfortunately and but the frustration
about my show is that I have to be
stupider than I want to be because my
character is so aggressively willfully
ignorant of what my guests are talking
about that sometimes I wish I could just
show slightly more knowledge because I'd
ask a better question but I tend to ask
I tend to I tend to emulate my audience
is ignorant about a subject
no no I love my audience what I mean
like the potential ignorance and if any
of you are in my audience I didn't mean
you or you and c-span people see me on
book TV and so that's where she is I'm
gonna answer I like that one okay let's
write that up we have a question over
here
where's over here yes mister called
there you are the reason I came to be ei
sorry yes yes die Southwest Florida
loves you but I have to ask how long are
you gonna hold out on us what have I
done
when will you be announcing your
candidacy for US president I would be do
I have your permission to write you in
if you do not declare well I certainly
can't you the right to write me in if
you want but I have made no decision in
that direction that's something I have
to do I sit down with my wife and my
family and my see what Fred Thompson
does first I also was on Law & Order by
the way I played a psychotic stamp
collector who kills old women with mail
bombs so I mean I have the same kind of
street cred he does anything I think we
have time for one more question I'll
make it really good we got one back here
I think it's gonna be a great question
it doesn't actually involve Colbert I'm
told okay thank you good night Diane has
a question my question is for Lisa C and
I was just puzzled at your discussion of
how well-educated at at some point in
time Chinese women were but at the same
time they were sold into whatever they
were sold into and why would they be
educated if the end result would just be
that the selling of them
to a man I guess there were lots of
women who are having very different
experiences so some yes we're sold like
fish with a value of less than salt but
some of these women were from very
wealthy families were very privileged
and so they lived in seclusion behind
their gates they were able to read and
write and all of those things so that
there was this this breadth of
experience just like there is for all of
us today and may I just say I forgot to
say something in my talk which is that
I've written peony in love as a ghost
story which is actually pretty important
and so that you do get a sense actually
this goes to your question of how women
would have experienced this
extraordinarily volatile time again I
think what's interesting is all of us
have been talking about women and men in
war and how this you know the social
turmoil that comes out of war and out of
religion and all of these things that do
have an effect on all of us
and so perhaps some of those people are
ghosts who continue to travel through
our lives well I want to thank Ken and
Lisa and Khaled for allowing me to
introduce them it was an honor to be up
here with you guys today and an honor to
speak to all of you and we all hope that
you have a fantastic book Expo thanks
very much
you